with the show as hilarious as the office
it's definitely worth taking the time to
watch all the blooper reels ok wait how
do you know it's a warehouse workers
thunk up the bathroom they stink up the
bathroom with their smelly poof's you
know they're gonna turn on us come on if
you don't have a lot of time on your
hands
never fear we've rounded up some of the
very best blooper reels from the office
right here in the season 2 episode
office olympics michael takes dwight to
the condo he's hoping to purchase Dwight
wastes no time making his boss highly
uncomfortable pointing out a string of
potential problems you'll be paying this
afternoon in 70s
forget about retiring when you're 65
but in this blooper from the episode
it's Dwight or rather active Rainn
Wilson who seems really rather
uncomfortable and the reason why soon
becomes clear I love you I love you
Michael
I love you too what are you even talking
about I was just talking about I farted
great to know that actors go through the
same struggles as the rest of us
sometimes actors can really miss the
mark take Phyllis Smith for example tell
us come on oh Jesus be alright jealous
are you alright are you okay she's not
the only office actor who occasionally
fails it's sticking the landing
it seems Brian Baumgartner has yet to
master the subtle art of sitting down
meanwhile in this season 5 episode
Michael Scott Paper Company
Steve Carell encounters some serious car
trouble
I think I'm gonna need some new pants
hey no one ever said getting out of cars
was easy we all have our things
well actor John Krasinski evidently
likes to pretend to get his finger
caught in clapper boards who wouldn't
want to try to hand it that clearly
Brian Baumgartner was eager to get in on
all the fun my joke my joke and he comes
Jenna Fischer to shown how it's really
done
teamwork he didn't get me everyone put
your hands together for these clapper
board cooks in the season 7 episode
viewing party the whole staff gathers a
Gabe's apartment to watch Glee and make
homemade pizzas so these are your
cheese's your hams your sausages your
herbs and your vegetables here's what's
been done start creating early on in the
episode Michael is seen throwing pizza
dough in the air and then this happens
try to destroy the old ways Gabe I will
not let you butt in one unused take the
scene goes a little bit differently burn
Appetit for an actor staying in
character takes a lot of hard work and
it can be tough to remember all those
lines in a scene from the season 4
episode in a party white unexpectedly
arrives at Michael's condo with two wine
glasses and a creepy date what are you
doing here we came here to eat dinner
under party obviously the same wasn't
shot in one take as this ridiculous
blooper proves what are you doing here
hi how are you I'm not in character yet
hey at least he's being honest
throughout season six Pam does
everything in her power to hold off
labor as she wrestles with the fear of
giving birth in a scene from the episode
the delivery part one Michael gathers
the staff to brainstorm how to slow down
Pam's pregnancy as Aaron reads off a
list of ways to stimulate labor the
group suggests ways of doing the exact
opposite okay number three eat spicy
foods okay the opposite of that stick
spicy food up her butt
nope nope for obvious reasons it took a
bit of work before to nail down this
particular scene take one what does the
opposite of that make spicy foods come
out of her okay nope no take two spicy
foods come out of No okay nope nope
we're not doing that Pam take three and
the opposite of that makes I see blue
turns out practice does make perfect
let's watch the final cut one more time
to bask in the glory okay number three
eat spicy foods okay the opposite of
that stick spicy food up her butt nope
nope check out one of their newest
videos right here Plus even more looper
videos about your favorite TV show so
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]